[Music]
on today's show we helped define
what does man of the family actually
mean we talked to a beautiful young mom
who's struggling with moving on after
losing her young child and we talked to
a mother of a teenage girl
who caught her and her boyfriend in
their room and they weren't studying
she wants to know what to do next stay
tuned
oh hey what's up this is john with the
dr john deloney's show
and i hope you are doing well
there's a lot of joy in the studio today
because kelly is gone
and amanda is sitting in for kelly james
the smiling face is here
zach's everybody's happy kelly's not
here because she's quote unquote with
her family
right her son's graduating or something
like that who prioritizes family over
work kelly what's wrong with america
these days
now actually i'm pretty excited man
that's pretty cool uh we work at a
pretty rad place
go be with your family man we'll there's
always somebody can step in here and
let's be honest this show is not rocking
science
it's not super complicated you're you're
special james your mom
raised a special fine young man and
amanda you are stellar and incredible
i'm just saying hey listen
on this show we talk about everything so
call us we'd love to have you on
1-844-693-3291 call leave a message
or go to johndaloni.com show and fill
out the form
hey before you get going i have a
producer note correction to make
okay the other day we were talking when
you did the lyrics of the day
tiny dancer we were making the joke
about tony danza
and i had thought it was from the office
and
why zach over here we were walking out
at the end of that day of the parking
lot
and he goes hey it wasn't the office it
was friends it was phoebe
and so i felt burdened to let our
audience know that we made a huge
mistake
i like how you screwed that up and you
collectively called it a wii but
as a good producer we're all on the same
team you always remind us
well done man i literally chased him
down in the parking lot i'm like no it
was from friends it was from friends
and so for those of you who don't know
insider baseball
the um video producer is not allowed to
speak back there
james just is back there with his
bullwhip he literally just spoke
oh that's true my microphone is on now
it works so everybody i was lying to you
i was trying to set james up as this
horrible villain he's not he's a great
guy
and listen we've got a crowd full of
people out here today
look at everybody out there all
beautiful and handsome
and handsome and beautiful it's good to
see everybody all right so
we get lots and lots of
emails bajillions of them phone calls
and they are
often y'all listen to show it's heavy
this is a heavy show and
occasionally we get one that is not so
heavy but people
still want to know the answer to it so
here we go we're going to start today's
show off with an email from angie
and here's what angie writes and i need
the folks in
the booth i need jealous wisdom on this
one angie writes
my husband and i are wondering if we
should allow our 13 year old
daughter to get a double piercing on her
ear
we have some hesitation and caution we
don't know if maybe we're being a bit
too
strict on that now mind you when you're
listening to this
the emails are about abuse
um just getting out of jail should we
stay married
i just caught my wife cheating filling
the blank
and then wonderful wonderful angie just
says can you help me out with this
should i let my daughter get her ears
double pierced
angie go with your gut on this one i
i don't yes i mean clearly the next step
is heroin addiction
i think you're no i'm kidding it's all
it's all relative you know if that's the
biggest
so this happened this happened in
college i came home from college and had
real long hair
and i think five earrings i was getting
tet
i was i was turning into that guy and i
remember my dad
in the car he looked at me just that
that shameful
cop looks at his son that went to
college and comes back looking like an
idiot
and he just said you get those things
out of your head or something like that
and i said dad if the extent of my
collegiate rebellion is that i punched
holes in the side of my head
you win you've won dad you've won all of
life and he looked at me
and smiled and said please just take him
out when we go to your grandmother's
house
and i thought that was a fair play that
is fair on a practical note when my
girls got their ears pierced recently
they get it's like so much maintenance
they get infected real easily
so just from a practical standpoint i'd
say just stick with the one
uh see we we have a weird thing in our
house we
our kids bathe every day and so they
don't get all these infections and
things like that but it's cool
to each their own if you are on a weekly
bathing schedule
probably stick to one stick to one oh
hey man you do wait your daughter's too
young to get her ears pierced but
pretty soon you'll see how it is you'll
come apologizing my daughter's got three
tattoos already she got one for a fit
she wanted them for her fifth birthday
that was like her thing you go disney
world honey no i want a dragon tattoo
on my back and so we did it it's cool
we're cool parents um angie yes
i go with your gut i don't have an even
opinion on this
um i wonder what the hesitation would be
yeah if my i'll put this away my 13 year
old daughter if if
that's the question that she asks me
when she's 13 i will do it myself
and we'll have a good time with it so
thank you for that let's go to
uh the phones let's go to jupe in denver
colorado
what's up jeep how we doing man doing
good doc how you doing today
good hey do you have kids um i do not
have any kids i have two nieces though
okay so pretend your niece wanted to get
double ear pierced is this a thing
um they actually do have their double
ears pierced how dare you
um did you lose sleep over it was it a
thing
not for me now unbelievable so far
as a society we're going down the toilet
juke just the truth
we are um i'd also like to um chime in
that
that song that that they uh sang on
friends yeah
that tony danza song um they did
actually sing it on the office as well
but it was a parody whenever michael
scott was handing out the dundees just
so you know
so everyone's correct jupe you are the
man you just made it full circle
hey dude i'm hanging up on you now i'm
kind of through with you i don't know
what we were going to talk about but
i'm kind of done listen i'll call in
later if you ever call into the show
never support man james does not need a
bigger head he's got a size
12 hat back there by the way all right
you so what's up how can i help
yeah so um uh number one thanks for
taking my call and also thank you kelly
for letting me be on the show
um but my my question is
um just to kind of the it's
um how do i believe
the pressure off of myself to be the
patriarch of our family
and provide is kind of the basis
of it um you said a lot of big words
i did um what do you what do you need me
to clarify
all of it okay so um
when i was um i basically had three
mentors in my life and it was my dad and
both of my grandparents or my
grandfathers
um everyone has been in the military all
of them were police officers all of them
served the greater good kinda and
they're just i what i would call a man's
man
men of honor and that kind of stuff um
and when i was 20
um my dad was killed in an accident and
then
um both of my grandfathers were killed
within the next 12 months as well well
they died of old age but either way
all the men in my family were basically
um
had died within 12 months and how old
are you now
i'm 28. wow that's a lot brother i'm
sorry that happened that's terrible
man yeah so um and
it was just always like talking about my
nieces um they're kind of like little
sisters i guess because
um my sister was 15 years older than i
is from my dad's previous marriage and i
grew up with them
as kind of like them being my little
sisters and
um i've always made it a point
like for example i moved across
a couple states to be with them whenever
my sister got a divorce from her first
husband
because i moved in because i knew that
they needed to have a man in the house
to kind of like show them
how a man is supposed to be and um now
that
i'm older i kind of just i don't know
how to like i also
i work a job full time and i'm i am
successful in my job
i also have a side business that i'm
running and i just don't know how to
relieve the pressure off of myself of
trying
to be successful and be the man of the
family and the patriarch i guess
so i i think man so i i get your heart
here
okay and i think is a
i think you're a really noble guy i
think you
care about your family and you saw a gap
and you did whatever i mean you packed
up and moved across country you did what
you could to
um wait with the tools you had in your
tool kit man you said man
i'm gonna make sure that there's a roof
over the head of everybody right
what i would do is challenge you to step
back a little bit
with this this you've mentioned a bunch
this idea of a quote-unquote man of the
house god have a man of the house god of
a man of the house
and somehow that has come
now you feel like you're at a crossroads
i either have to be this or
i want to go pursue a career in what i
want to be and what i want to do
and so i want to i want you to back up a
little bit define for me what
the man of the house means what does
that mean
so not not what you were not where you
were and not you had some studs
um some service oriented tough guys
right in your life yeah and don't look
back at the things you
did or didn't do when you just hear
somebody say man of the house what does
that mean
me being the man of the house or like
the patriarch of the family i know it's
a
big term but um it's being
the person that people look up to and
people go to
when things are hard it's like the rock
that your family leans on
and what are the sacrifices in your mind
that the rock
makes in order to fulfill that position
that role
um i would say um
putting their own emotions to the side
okay i suppose like not showing
um lots of weakness whenever everyone
else is kind of having a hard time
okay
how honest do you want me to be with you
you know
doc i appreciate your straightforward
approach so
whatever you got bring it on you did
tell james that he
he wasn't as dumb as he thought he was i
did
all right so you can use that as amazon
i won't
so um you if you've been listening the
show long you know i've worked behind
closed doors with
cops military folks and that
my dad's a homicide attack like you know
that that's my been my universe for a
long time
and what i would tell you is this idea
of quote-unquote
patriarch this
this stoic rock that puts that shoves
emotions
in a drawer so that the rest of a family
can anchor into that
dude i think that's one of the greatest
ills of our current society
and here's why when people anchor into
an emotionless
rock it makes any emotions that they
feel
it makes them feel sick makes them feel
broken or not
normal not not um
yeah not normal it makes him feel like
oh gosh i have to be
that which is really robotic right
and i think the greatest
gift a male presence in the in
the life of um nieces and nephews
and sisters and sons and daughters and
mothers
is to both do the right things
right make sure you take care of
yourself and you set a good example and
you live a highly disciplined life
and you treat people with dignity and
respect but also
that you let people know when you're
scared and when you're really sad
and you're frustrated and so people get
to watch somebody experience these
feelings
have them own them this sucks
my heart is broken i'm super sad
and we've all got some hard decisions to
make tomorrow i've got to get up
i need to not eat that i'm still going
to go work out
or i'm not going to work out i'm going
to sit here and hold my kid because
she's upset right
and so it's this it's the ability to do
both and and i think culturally we've
lost both and
we're either and or we're all both right
it's all one side or the other
either this idea of a masculine presence
has been just
beaten up and discarded or
it has been over magnified
right and so what i will tell you is
it's when
a police officer who's shot somebody can
weep
and say i can't believe that had to
happen i can't believe i'm
there then they're able to go back to
their job with empathy that that the job
demands
it's when they can look at their wife
and say i'm so sorry i haven't been here
for so long
or they can look at their husband and
say i'm so sorry that i'm bringing my
cop work home and what makes me an
effective
police officer here makes me not a great
wife or husband here
that's when you can start to see healing
in some of those relationships so i
would tell you
the greatest gift you could give your
nieces
is to be a super successful
business person in whatever you want to
do and
make sure you call them regularly and
make sure you know about who they're
dating and make sure you're poking fun
at whoever they're dating
and make sure that they that you show up
when you're able to
and that you facetime them and then that
they know that they have a place in your
heart and that they have value
and that you are also doing the things
that you need to do
every day does that make sense it's less
of a cartoon character
in a little green gi joe man and more of
a
living breathing guy who is vulnerable
and who is open
and who still gets up and does the hard
things that he needs to do and by the
way
moms all across the country are rock
solid people
that hold homes together and hold
families and marriages together
and are safe places to go and so i think
what you did was a really noble thing
and your family is is been gifted for
generations
because of what you did i also think
it's time that you can show them
hey i'm really struggling with this this
is hard for me and i love you guys i'm
afraid that if i go work really hard on
my business you aren't going to get the
attention
you deserve and i'm going to do the best
i can and i think those kind of
vulnerable open conversations
those man those are legacy changing
so when i tell you that how does that
sound to you do i sound like
some kind of wimp 20 like a millennial
weenie with tight jeans and a mustache
no not at all also i'm a millennial i
resent that but no
um well played that uh that absolutely
makes total sense it's being
being both without having to be a stoic
rock being um being being able to
express yourself and still being able to
be there for people
anytime you feel like you have to live
into this
mythological role that's when you're
going to get yourself in trouble
because you're going to become a
caricature of yourself and when you're
playing a role
people that you love can tell you're not
being you
you're not being authentic you are
pretending to be a thing
you are sliding into i'll ah
dad's not here so i'll become dad well
everybody knows you're not dead
what they need is uncle they need
brother
does that make sense and that takes a
lot of pressure off of you to be
something that you're not
it lets you a lot of pressure off them
to treat you some weird
hybrid way and then everybody can
experience grief together enjoy together
and laughter together
and you still need to be doing taking
care of your business right but i would
be telling you that
if you were saying hey i need to fill
this stereotypical maternal role too
instead of trying to fill these roles
as a as an uncle i just need you to sit
back and relish the fact that you're a
pretty good guy
and you were raised well and now it's
time to let your
nieces and nephews know the full you
brother
all of it right all of it so go do your
business well
and write them a letter once a week do
things like that that they're going to
be able to hold and see
and experience and feel tell them when
you are scared
tell them when you have a hard business
decision to make
let them know call them and say hey this
is really hard for me
you will give them more peace and make
them feel less nuts you will make them
feel less
lonely in a world where everybody's a
cartoon character right now
you're going to give them a dose of
humanity that they don't have god
almighty what a gift that will be
so jube good heart brother i'm proud to
have um it's an honor i've gotten to
speak to you today
now i want you to put down the quote
unquote paternal the man of the house
just breathe continue to speak the truth
be respectful treat people with dignity
continue to take care be a good steward
of your body
work out take care of yourself make sure
you're able to handle yourself
so that you never have to
and then also don't be too big to hold
your nieces tell them that you're scared
be honest with them man that's
generational that's
that's legacy shifting brother good for
you man all right let's go out to
hannah in dallas texas hannah what's
going on
hi doctor john how are you i'm all right
how about you
kind of take it one day at a time uh oh
so what's going on
all right no that's okay that's all
right take your time
um
here watch me this dude do a favor for
me i want you to take a deep breath as
you can i want you to hold it
and i'm gonna count to three okay
breathe it in as deep as you can
hold it for one two
three and then let it out
and then do it again and this time i
want you to breathe in through your nose
okay
breathe in as deep as you can hold it
one two
three and then just blow it out
that really helps and i'm glad that you
called what's up
well a couple months ago
my husband and i lost our first daughter
oh my god
i'm so sorry
thanks
what a nightmare yeah
she had a chromosomal disorder and
so we we saw it coming
and so we were savoring every moment
with her but
it doesn't matter right yeah
yeah we have a piece about like
everything that happened
and we we kind of understand it as well
as we can
but it just it doesn't take away the
pain
yeah so what what are the last two
months been like
uh the first month wasn't bad we were
like as bad as it could have been you
know sure um
i feel like it was still like a lot of
shock and a lot of
times just being able to
remember her and make
honor her i guess through
writing things about her and telling
people about her but
um the past month it's been getting a
little harder
and i
i guess i don't really know very well
how to cope
and manage the grief as it's just been
getting harder so when you say getting
harder
what does that mean
like feeling like i'm gonna cry at the
drop of a hat
all the time and i'm just thinking about
her constantly
and before it was really easy to hear
well i mean i guess it wasn't easy but
it was
it didn't feel as painful
to hear about other people's kids and
other people's
births and now people
like i see them getting on
with their pregnancies and their births
and people just talking about passing
away
and like just with older people
and those things are just starting to
hit a little closer and making me
miss her more and more
how are you and your husband
i think we're doing okay i know we could
be doing better
um but
yeah i don't know so we love each other
well right it's like a mis
it just has felt like misconnection for
a while yeah
so how far along in your pregnancy did
you did you know this was coming
we were 20 weeks when we found out that
something was wrong
and how how long did you carry uh 38
weeks
okay wow so another another few months
okay
so
what you described so beautifully the
last
the first month is
a really remarkable defense mechanism
our bodies have
which is almost this disconnection from
everything
just so we can get through the
day-to-day the day-to-day right
and as you're you begin to plug back in
is your body
and i hate this analogy but as it starts
to come back online the reality of what
happened
hurts so bad yeah
and you've been grieving this for a long
time you were grieving this at 20 months
at you know 20 20 weeks right
and husbands and wives always grieve
these things differently which
then feels like there's a gap between
them and there's something
we're not okay or we could be like as
you said we could be doing better
and that spins different different alarm
systems off right so
hear me say this wherever you are right
now
is okay
and if you feel like crying real hard i
want you to have permission to cry real
hard
and if you don't want to leave the house
for a minute don't leave the house for a
minute
there's a few things i'll tell you in
here in a minute that i want to make
sure that you've got
um that you've you've
got at your fingertips to make sure
you've got people that are walking with
you in this deal
but there's not a lot of shoulds
everybody's grief looks different
everyone's looks painful everyone's
looks or not everyone looks painful some
people just
move right on other people are
devastated other people
comes in waves everyone's looks
different
tell me about this little baby's funeral
how did y'all how did y'all celebrate
her life
my husband and i both wrote uh i guess
stories about the week that we had with
her
and just how much we loved her and
i made her a little dress out of my
wedding dress
oh wow really beautiful
my husband bought her a necklace three
little hearts
and we had
all of our family come and a lot of our
really close friends and community come
and support us
we did a slide show we had pictures
and my husband uh
kind of gave i guess a eulogy of
her life and just how much she changed
us and
how much we love her
so hannah i've heard um
i i don't i don't know the number of
folks i've talked to over the years
in a similar situation and that may be
the most beautiful
um celebration i've ever heard
it's incredible and
it doesn't mean it hurts any less and it
doesn't mean
what happened is okay it doesn't mean
that y'all aren't um
still wrestling every minute of every
day
yeah but it's beautiful and i'm glad
that y'all did that that's
really remarkable so as you're
navigating this a month later
this becomes super real right and
not only that is as
it's some at some level your body is
still re-regulating itself after a
pregnancy
there's a lot going on do you have a
doctor you're continuing to work with
kind of not really no i think we're done
with doctors
no okay i can imagine that's not a happy
place right now
so if you find yourself um increasingly
unable to function
if you increasingly i'm i'm
getting out of bed feels like i've got a
backpack full of cinder blocks on
right um i can't move my legs out of my
bed
i want you to make a phone call to your
doctor okay
and i also want you to make sure that
you have
a couple of women in your life either
they've experienced something similar or
you have
100 trust in them and you can reach out
to them and
let them know that you're my go-to and
i'm going to text you at all hours of
the night i'm going to text you
crazy things that come to my mind i'm
going to call you crying i'm going to
call you laughing and if i say hey i
need
i need tacos now y'all gonna come and
that they'll show up
okay do you have those people in your
life yeah
yeah i do and you trust them
i trust soap it's just i don't want to
feel i guess
like i'm i'm burdening them okay i know
that they'd be there
but there you go so you don't um you're
gonna have to let that go for a season
okay that's why we have other people
they hold our hands up and our arms up
when we can't that's why we have
community
right yeah so
a really important place for you to
zero in soon is with your husband okay
and um
i did not understand what my wife was
going through
in not quite the same situation but
um related i didn't get it i didn't
understand
and it was after a couple of really hard
and direct
conversations that my eyes were opened
in a pretty significant way
and so whether you can do that directly
or he can hear that or do that with you
share that with you directly
or you all need to go get somebody that
you trust to to
sit with both of you i want you all to
make sure a
you're giving each other space to grieve
however y'all grieve
and everybody does this differently you
can't get in the grief comparison game
it's real easy for you to start saying
hey man are you going to get over this
we got to move on and him to start
saying hey when are we going to try for
all that stuff feels so intrusive and
hard and messy and gross
and making sure y'all are setting aside
dedicated time
that y'all are on the same page and
you're both giving each other permission
to be heard
and to speak and the more you speak and
the more open you feel and the more you
all reconnect
not that it makes this thing hurt less
but your
your body knows that you've got somebody
to share this burden with
it helps with the healing okay the other
other way this happens so often is one
of you starts to move on faster than the
other
the other person becomes devastated by
that and you just get into this
dance that will haunt your marriage for
years and years
it all starts and ends with you both of
you being willing to be open and
compassionate
and quiet with one another and
to be able to speak truth to each other
are y'all in a position where you can do
that are you willing to try that
for sure yeah okay
at some point you'll begin to the
the hard but more light the more
optimistic turn
which is making meaning of this why us
why did that beautiful little baby have
a chromosome issue
why why did i carry to term
a beautiful kid and only get to spend
five six seven days with her
why did we have to do this why did our
families have to come up for this
why me why my husband y'all begin to
make me what are we going to do now
and that's when you begin to take this
pain and this frustration and this why
and you turn it into so now
right you begin to make meaning out of
this thing and that looks different for
everybody
whether you become a go-to resource for
folks experiencing a similar thing
whether you become
um you already are the greatest mom i've
talked to in a long time
um you become even more
cognizant of what's coming that of your
next kid that comes along
or or or or meaning making looks
different for everybody but you'll get
there
right now isn't that time it's not to
beat yourself up for crying it's not to
beat yourself up because i can't get out
of bed it's not to beat yourself up
because i haven't talked to my husband
in a while
there's not a playbook for people's
grief right now it's to experience it
and to feel it and make sure you got
people around you
and then there's a little things make
sure you're eating right make sure
you're showering make sure you're
drinking water
make sure you get outside and go for a
walk right the little things we forget
to do we look up we haven't eaten in a
week right
um have you been there yet or you
haven't showered in a week
no i'll keep showering
good for you it's your husband that's
not gross gross
but yeah make sure you're doing the
little things and if you don't have
somebody to text you along the way
right that will just say hey we're going
to get lunch you're eating and you'll
say i'm not hungry and they'll say well
too bad cause i'm showing up with
enchiladas right whatever that looks
like but make sure you got people to
walk alongside you
here's the person i want you to really
love and honor over the next 30 to 60
days
okay hannah hey
cool
yeah i want hannah to write hannah a
letter
and i want hannah to acknowledge what a
great mom hannah is
i want hannah to acknowledge how much
this sucks
moms are not supposed to bury kids
they're just not it's not how
it's not supposed to work
and i want hannah to talk to hannah
about what tomorrow might look like
what the future might look like
but i want hannah to be really graceful
with hannah right now
you are right in the middle of it okay
and like i said if it gets too heavy
please be brave and call somebody
you promise me that no problem
okay it's one of the greatest honors
of my professional life to get to talk
to you
thank you
do you promise me you're gonna let
yourself cry
yeah i will good now like you got a
choice though
right right
before we go i want you to tell me one
thing that you wrote in that letter to
your daughter
how thankful i was that
god gave her to me so that i could love
her
in that few days you had with her what
was the sliver of joy she brought you
i got to hold her and she had the
squishiest face
the little fingers and 12 toes that were
our favorites
ah they're the cutest not cute thing at
all when they're two-day right
yeah and everyone has to lie to
everybody like look how cute and they're
never like oh how cute and everyone
knows that everybody's lying right
brother's nothing like that squishy face
on your chest huh
there's nothing like it yeah and there
never will be
yeah you're a brave
tough vulnerable spirit and i'm grateful
for you hannah
thank you honor that baby
honor hannah honor your marriage make
sure you reach out for help
make sure you got a group of people
walking with you make sure your gross
husband is showering
[Applause]
hello and i want you to keep us updated
on your journey here okay
um don't hesitate to write us back if
i mean if things take a turn sideways
give me a call back
give me a call back
oh here's one more thing you're gonna
get
listen you're gonna get the stupidest
advice
you've ever heard in your life you're
going to get the dumbest
cliched cheese ball sayings you're going
to start
seeing more of your friends
pregnant your the the coveted numbers
are gonna
you know the people getting sick people
passing away those are gonna look like
giant neon red flashing lights it's just
your
heart and mind scanning the environment
for another opportunity for you to get
hurt i want you to know
it feels like things are closing in on
you
and they're not you're surrounded by
people who love you
you're surrounded by a guy that loves
you and you're and you're strong
and you're tough but now's not the time
for strong and tough now's the time for
weeping and mourning
thanks for honoring us hannah here's my
promise to you
there's a lot of women a lot of men
listening to this right now
who have experienced that know
somebody's experiencing that and just
hearing your heart and walking through
that
is a gift so thank you so much for
sharing that with us
one of the most common questions folks
ask me is what they should do when
anxiety or panic strikes like a
lightning bolt
i've been helping folks 101 for years
but i wanted to create something that
everyone could use anywhere at any time
so i created a free
guided meditation it's not really a
meditation but really me just
walking with you through your anxiety
alarms from start
to finish i'll guide you through a
breathing exercise and show you how to
lean in
listen and head towards healing it is
free and it's for
everyone you can download this guided
meditation today for free at
johndaloni.com
take one more call let's go to uh mary
in champaign illinois mary what's going
on how are we doing
hi john um thank you for taking my call
i'm really excited to talk to you today
and i'm thank excited
we'll see they always think i am until
they actually call
so what's up well we'll see um so
i'm looking for some advice on how to
navigate a conversation with my
daughter's
boyfriend's parents um to kind of give
you a little bit of background
yes i think i know it's coming please
tell me i'm right
you're probably right um so she's 16 and
they're all getting this boy
there are no good conversations that
begin with i need help talking to my
daughter's boyfriend's parents you are
absolutely right
it's gonna sound like i'm laughing at
you i promise i'm not but my daughter's
five my time will come but it's not here
yet so i'm with you on this
okay so yeah i interrupted your
daughter's 16. now that's okay
um she is 16 she's been dating a boy for
about six months
and which is like basically forever when
you're 16. it's a thousand years yes
yes so um things are getting or feeling
i guess
pretty serious um she
um had him over last week and
basically what happened is
you started this call so good so like
all right i need your advice on this
thing that happened here
and now that we're getting closer you're
circling this thing like
like a record player in slo-mo it's like
it's unfolding
so then a thing happened at our house
and you know right barry white
was on the record player and all right
so walk me into this here we go
so i was busy with my other kids we were
all together
you know hanging out watching a movie um
i was i got busy with the other kids
and uh everybody kind of went outside
and i was like okay well it's time for
me to do something you know around the
house
so i asked my daughter and her boyfriend
to do a thing
and i thought they went and did a thing
but they did something else oh they did
a thing all right
[Laughter]
so luckily i didn't i didn't actually
visualize the things that happened
um i only heard what happened
and then yeah i think i'd rather
see it than hear it yeah i think she
thought that i was outside
so um i just made it blatantly clear
that i was not outside
and then it was super awkward after that
but i did not confront them or have a
conversation
at that moment i thought it wouldn't
really be helpful because i was probably
a little emotional and
you know feeling some kind of way um yes
i decided to table that conversation
okay i know it's about to get serious
but so before we take a turn into like
this is actually this is hard i know
this is hard no no parent i know
but i have to know what's the thing you
said
so i didn't say anything to them did you
just make really loud noises
what did you do it honestly just got
very loud like i started to do dishes
and playing things around
you know you didn't make them you didn't
go charging into the room
no so do they know that you know yes
they are aware so we actually tabled the
conversation he left not long after that
and i just didn't say anything um
and then my husband and i had a
conversation with our daughter
separately we're pretty open about these
things we're aware that teenagers are
teenagers and they have hormones and
they're going to do things
yeah and so our daughter wasn't super
uncomfortable to talk about it which is
very odd because i was very
uncomfortable
but we did have a conversation with her
but now i'm wondering
how to go about having a conversation
with a
do i have a conversation with her and
her boyfriend together and
how do i talk to parents about this
because
at some point she's going to need or not
me too but wants to go to his
house and hang out okay and we have to
set some boundaries
and have some conversations and i just i
don't know where they are his parents
are
on this you know journey and so i just
kind of want to
i guess set a precedence of boundaries
yeah so so you don't have a relationship
with her number one
thanks for letting me laugh along with
you um i'm just projecting into the
future here
in my own house and so um i don't
i appreciate you letting us all walk
alongside you
and actually you went way ahead of us
all
we're just watching um and so in all
seriousness yeah i know this is hard um
yeah that's just hard and so
oh man this one's kind of messy so you
don't know his parents you don't really
have a relationship with him
other than okay um i know him way better
than i know his parents he mostly comes
to our house
um so she doesn't usually visit there
and i have just
you know seen his father in passing uh
pick up drop off
we have talked about having them over
for dinner and
honestly just never really got around to
it but now i know that absolutely needs
to happen now
so hey listen yeah
that would be the greatest parent
revenge dinner of all time
like we're gonna have his parents over
and we're all gonna talk about this
together
that would be the most legend baller
parent move of all time
if that happens record it because it
will be
a youtube sensation will pay your house
off it would be incredible goodness
man oh yeah because how old is this cat
is he
16 too he's also 16 yeah okay so
this is one of those things that the
world has shifted a little bit
underneath
us if this had happened when i was 16
i feel like in that universe
parents trusted other parents to have
these type of conversations with their
kids
now we're in a world where i just don't
it doesn't it doesn't it doesn't feel
right to me anymore
and so for you to go about talking to
him
now if he came over and you wanted to
address
the boundaries of your home i think
that's
fully okay um and so one would be a
boundaries conversation and one would
might be the moral character
like i'll tell this kid like not my
daughter that conversation right
right so backing out first and foremost
high five to you for raising a 16 year
old that y'all could have this
conversation it wasn't weird for y'all
no it really wasn't we actually laughed
more than it was awkward
so listen you're doing you are you are
way ahead of the curve yeah it would
have been more awesome if you'd run in
there screaming and yelling and
and throwing water on it whatever um
but the fact that you recognized i'm not
going to handle this well right this
second
i'm going to let them know that i'm
going to put a stop to this by letting
them know
that i'm here and i know what's going on
and
i'm going to get control of my emotions
before i approach this good for you
high five to you that's awesome second
is both you and your husband address
this that's awesome and you addressed it
obviously in a way that
um allowed for some levity and some
seriousness
what i often see people do is try to
treat their 16 year olds and 17 year
olds and 18 year olds like their 10 year
olds
right my 10 year old i can end your
world i can cut off your
communication in the outside world
16 year olds will go hook up in an
arby's parking lot right i mean it's a
different game unless you just say
you're homeschooling now you don't get
any electronics i'm going to cut you and
then
then you're on borrowed time right then
you're 700 days away from them saying
bye right yeah and so there there is a
that in my house these are my boundaries
these are my rules and
man you're if i'm gonna default to
relationship more than
than um excommunication right that's a
hard
the fishy scary boundary how'd your
husband handle this
um he surprisingly wasn't as upset as i
thought he would be
i talked to him about it first and then
we talked about it
and how we were going to approach it
with her we kind of made a game plan
and then we talked about it with her so
we made sure that none of the other kids
were around and we had her by herself
and you know we just
kind of brought it up and you know just
said okay we know
that something's happening i don't know
what the thing is but
there's some stuff happening and you
know we need to
talk about it and really talk about the
boundaries in our home
and you know where do we go from here
and the fact that you and your husband
put your heads together and talked about
it and came up with a plan that y'all
shared together i mean that's just
parent 101 you're
you're way far ahead good for you guys
so at the end of the day
um because he's a child this kid's a
child
i would give his parents a heads up um
that's just me i'd call him and say hey
look this happened at our house
and we talked to our daughter about it
we like your son um
we don't hate him we don't think
anybody's evil but because they're kids
we
we thought it was right for you to know
and um
i that's how i would handle this again
you never know what's coming what's next
um
they may say so like they're 16
yeah or they may say oh my gosh you're
breaking up right away
and there's no communication ever you
never know how that's going to go
when it that's the the hard crappy part
about having boundaries is you can't be
responsible for other people's response
to your boundaries
right so one of my boundaries is if
there is a
child acting um
not being safe whether that's playing
out in the road
or um
whatever the thing happens to be i'm
going to bring the other parents into
the loop i'm just going to let them know
right again 20 30 years ago you had that
conversation
with the two of them and then it stays
there they still don't think we're there
anymore
and so i always want to make partners
with um other parents in my community
with kids
so i wouldn't hold on to that i would be
ready for the ramifications of that this
may all be fun and not fun in games but
relationship building your daughter got
to hear from you i think this is an
awesome opportunity for you not without
dad
to take daughter out and
you heard her so now it's time for her
to listen to you
and you can tell her about your teenage
years you can tell her about
your awkward experiences how
um even when you're married things can
get off the rails and weird and hard and
unexpected and awkward i think this is a
time for you
to really speak into that relationship
between you and your daughter i think
that could be a really
magic season for y'all and she is gonna
you can melt her and it's a i hope you
do right i hope you do
um but in a day you could call this
guy's parents and he could
get cut off and then your daughter's
gonna turn on you expect
that could happen and that doesn't mean
you did the wrong thing
okay um that means that his parents have
different values and different
boundaries than you guys do
and that's just part of it your
daughter's gonna you're playing a long
game with her now she's gonna know
that you at the end of the day you're
doing what you could to keep her safe
and to keep her tethered to the values
that your family has whatever they may
be
i do have to know are you nervous about
that conversation you feel empowered
about it like
tell me about how that really nervous
about that conversation i don't
so tell me why i'm i honestly
i don't know that we have the same
values as in
i'm honestly worried that it's going to
be a so what
like no big deal um and then i will have
to put some really strong
firm boundaries about her visiting his
house
and so that is kind of what i am
concerned about he really
likes his family a lot and i think she
wants to continue
you know going there and you know
and trying to build that relationship
with his family but if they don't aren't
really on the same page
with values then i feel like i should
not let her
go there if that makes sense
i think this is a really pivotal time
for you
and your daughter's relationship i
wholeheartedly support you
your values are your values and if you
don't want her in an unsafe situation
then that's your right as a parent
and um i i hope
and i know this is easier said than done
i hope that you will
always feel affirmed in your parent
values whatever they happen to be
and i hope you will always default to
relationship too
which it sounds like you all clearly
have
but if you have to draw some boundaries
and say the only time you can see this
this boy are at my at our house
and if you violate those then it's not
going to be that
you saw this boy it's that now we can't
trust you because we put a boundary up
whatever that happened to be
and you violated the boundary then it's
not about the the
action number one it's about number two
right um this is an important season for
you guys
a really important season and so for
whatever it's worth
from the outside it sounds like you guys
are handling this with the right amount
of humor
and grace and communication
in your marriage with your kids good for
you guys all the way across
my hope is that 20 years from now she's
married to some knucklehead and this
becomes a hilarious
thanksgiving story you'll tell over and
over
and that this becomes a really
remarkable time that you can teach her
um about valuing herself
and what love looks like and how messy
relationships can get and because you've
walked there right
and that can be a really vulnerable
honest time between you and her
and it could get really off the rails
and so if it gets off the rails
i hope that you will continue to loot
back to your default this first time
around
which is i'm gonna make sure my husband
and i are on the same page
we're always gonna we're gonna head into
these these value conversations together
we're gonna make sure we're not putting
our daughter on blast in front of our
other kids
unless it's really funny then it's gotta
come up at the dinner table
for sure um
that you and you're continuing to honor
her in that relationship how she chooses
to revolt and
throw her 16 year old fits against up
and up and down against your boundaries
that's her deal that's what 16 year olds
do
right that doesn't mean you're wrong or
out of whack or out of balance
20 years from now she'll think you have
five ten years from now she'll thank you
but
yeah you said it best six-month
relationships are a thousand-year
marriages to sixteen-year-olds
everything's the most dramatic thing
ever and oh my gosh you took away my
love huh um
so here high five to you parent to
parent way to go mary
but yeah i'd make that conversation i'd
have that conversation
and um i would i wouldn't
i wouldn't i would do my best to not let
my heart rate get up
one beat extra you have nothing to be
ashamed about your values are your
values
you've got nothing to um
um the unknown is the unknown but you're
doing the right thing
good for you well thank you so much i
appreciate
your help and your insight to some it's
just i don't know it's just kind of
messy it feels really
overwhelming so it does and tell
tell let your daughter in on that too
okay and
when you say hey you're still a child
you're a kid she'll be like no
i'm 16. i can drive and i can hook up
with my boyfriend when you guys are out
in the yard
i can do whatever i want like yeah i
know and you're
still 16. right and that's it's so hard
you might as well start telling her i
used to go uphill in the snow
to school both ways it's like that
you're in that territory
back when i was a kid metallica was
really heavy battle you're i know you
all sound like that but um
those conversations and that that
continuing to go back to relationship
back to relationship back to values back
to values back to relationship
trump's everything good for you good for
you
um hey if you will do me a huge favor
this is this isn't for the audience it's
just for me personally
i have to know how that conversation
goes so if you'll write back
um and let us know how it goes or call
back and leave a message
and if it's a disaster if they did heard
that guy's dad just starts laughing at
you you idiot what a nerd
let me know that too um then he'll be an
idiot but
um anyway give me a call back i gotta
know how this ends
uh but thank you so much for the call
mary i just got so many feelings on this
i have so many feelings i have so many
jokes that i want to make
i have so many things that i want to
announce to 16 year olds that i'm not
going to announce oh my gosh dude my
kids are
eleven and five i'm not ready for this
james we need to
we need to produce a subscriber paid
subscription
podcast version where you just say
what's exactly
yeah we could make a fortune you'd only
last two episodes before we got canceled
but it would be spectacular
it would be spectacular well so hey as
we wrap up today's show
yep every once in a while
the stars are lined ladies and gentlemen
this starts the line you know those
moments when
uh nope we're just gonna do this so
tommy james in the shondells wrote a
song a long time ago
it was cool but it was re-recorded
back when i was a kid by the one and
only tiffany
and in light of mary from champaign's
extraordinary adventure in her own home
the song of today is by the
aforementioned tiffany
it's called i think we're alone now and
it goes like this
children behave that's what they say
when we're together
and watch how you play they don't
understand
oh honey marry your mom she understands
and so we're running just as fast as we
can can
can holding on to one another's hand
trying to get away into the night and
then you put your arms around me and we
tumble to the ground and then you say
i think we're alone now you're clearly
not
there doesn't seem to be anyone around i
think we're alone now the beating of our
hearts is the only sound
except for mary out in the living room
saying hello
i can hear you i think we're alone now
there doesn't seem to be anyone around
we all thought that when we were 16 and
we were all wrong
this has been the dr john dolone show
[Music]
you